[Musique]
salut à tous vous êtes bien sur
envergure Underdogs épisode 3 je suis
avec Manu et Mathias salut les gars
salut salut aujourd'hui on va parler de
deux joueurs relativement âgés mais pas
inintéressants pour autant on va aller
plutôt dans l'Ouest euh pour commencer
euh du côté de creayton avec un joueur
qui nous intéresse au douom de Baylor
schyerman qui est-il Manu alors Baylor
schyerman c'est un un grand monsieur de
67 en en chaussures je je précise en
chaussures donc 67 ça fait 2 m 2,5
quelque chose comme ça à vun nez donc
c'est sa deuxe saison à à kayton après
avoir transféré de de South Dakota state
où il a joué trois saisons donc c'est un
super senior avec euh donc c'est sa 5e
saison en en nca voilà quatre frères et
sœurs fans de Pit Maravic et des Frères
Scott j'adore cette cette
anecdote avec une première voiture qui a
été un minivan incroyable aussi
originaire du Nebraska donc Kayon et
sumit League Player of the Year en 2022
donc avant de quitter nor South Dakota
state avant de de rejoindre une plus
grosse conférence une plus grosse équipe
avec kon où où il est titulaire sur ces
sur ces deux saisons là
avec eux ça fonctionne comment kayton
j'ai l'impression que c'est basé sur
deux trois joueurs qui apportent
beaucoup au niveau de la production et
qu' après c'est un peu plus dispersé
ouais bah tu as une option numéro une
plus ou moins qui est qui est très
Alexander the third qui est Paris c'est
un un senior voilà donc c'est vraiment
lui la la tête de gundle de l'équipe et
puis il y a il y a Steve Ashford le
l'autre l'autre meneur qui est qui est à
ses côtés donc lui c'est plus plus
deuxème option offensive quand il a
besoin d'un trois points il va être là
pour pour artiller et B saerman qui
voilà qui est aussi lui présent à à
l'extérieur sur sur les tirs notamment
c'est on en reviendra sur son jeu après
mais voilà c'est vraiment plus la
troisième option un joueur capable de de
d'envoyer des des points à l'extérieur
mais aussi à l'intérieur qui est un peu
dommage pour nous envergure on est vous
savez qu'on à quel point on est attaché
au projet capillaire il a changé le
projet capillaire cette année depuis un
petit moment avant il avait un
magnifique bandeau et les cheveux un peu
de Milon et là maintenant il a été rasé
mais ça reste un bon joueur un très bon
joueur moi j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup je vais laisser après
Mathias rebondir sur ce que je dis mais
c'est un un poste 34 en NCA qui est
capable de d'artiller dans tous les sens
il y a vraiment une belle diversité dans
dans le tir notamment à trois points
donc ça peut être du catch et une shoot
à l'arrêt en mouvement en sortie d'écran
il y a pas trop de création pour lui à
l'extérieur mais il peut il peut aller
emb éé crée un peu d'espace des fois
c'est voilà le il a pas encore cette
qualité athlétique qui lui permett de
créer de l'espace de prendre de la
vitesse et et ce genre de choses mais
c'est un un shooter incroyable comme je
disais extérieur mais aussi mi-distance
qui commence un peu à m-distance et sur
la seconde chance au rebond aussi il est
très très important il prend énormément
de rebond j'étais assez surpris en
voyant ses stats il a en en carrière
donc sur ces sur ces cinq saisons avec
avec en NC il est il a plus de se
rebonds donc j'ai trouvé ça assez
intéressant et et des deux côtés il a
près d'un rebond offensif par match donc
c'estut dire qu'il se bat vraiment
beaucoup et je je trouve moi sur le film
que j'ai vu qu'effectivement il il y va
il a pas peur de d'aller à la mayilloche
et de d'aller ne seraisse qu'embêter
l'adversaire pour bah pour que le ballon
déve et tombe dans dans les mains de ses
coéquipiers donc je le trouve vraiment
un super intéressant ouais c'est un
c'est un vieux joueur entre guillemets
mais c'est un qui reste en fait ê très
intéressant dans ce qu'il apporte il va
être utile tout de suite dans une équipe
professionnelle je pense bah la pass d'
est toute faite Mathias au niveau
qu'est-ce que toi tu tu vois quand tu
vois l'hyper productif Bayer Sherman bah
je pense que Manu il a bien régeté les
les qualités premières de de bayor c'est
le shooter par excellence moi je suis
impressionné par la la la la la
diversité et la difficulté des choses
qui prend et puis euh ce qui est
intéressant avec lui c'est sa taille
quoi il fait 2 M1 mais aussi avec des
qualités de de playmaking tu sais c'est
c'est forward qui peuvent aussi jouer
avec le ballon en main de temps en temps
en phase offensive il est quand même à à
plus de quatre passes de moyenne donc
pour un pour un ch de sa taille c'est
quand même pas inintéressant et puis
ouais un pourcentage au lancer franc qui
fait que confirmer ses qualités au shoot
donc euh shootur fiable sur les passes
c'est c'est quatre passes mais quasiment
sur sur son cursus universitaire tu
c'est pas c'est pas une saison il a
trois saisons à plus de quatre passes h
donc c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui qu' a toujours eu qu'il a et qui
développe en fait au fil des des saisons
donc c'est intéressant de mettre le
point là-dessus et qu'est-ce qui fait
que si vous êtes scout c'est un nom que
vous cochez et que vous ne rayez pas eu
moi c'est plus sur sa diversité de tir
VO il est il est super intéressant
là-dessus à trois points quelqu'un qui
shoot à quasiment 40 % sur 5 saisons NCA
à 3 points c'est juste incroyable c'est
voilà c'est élite comme dirait l'autre
donc c'est vraiment pour ça ça sa
capacité à à marquer à TR points et à à
être diversifié dans dans ce qu'il
propose sur le tir comme disais au début
c'est du catch shoot à l'arrêil en
mouvement ça va être en sortie d'écran
voilà s'il est trouvé libre il y a qu de
chance que ça que ça filoge donc c'est
c'est vraiment ça moi ça son skill
numéro 1 pour pour lequel je le drafte
ouais Mathias tu es sur la même chose
son tir
ouais bah ouais c'est c'est ce qui
marque même si euh quand on regarde les
stats il est un peu en perdition au
niveau du pourcentage mais bon ça
s'explique aussi par le volume et puis
la difficulté des shoots ouais c'est ça
le le le volume est assez énorme là
j'avais regardé juste avant de préparer
l'émission on est déjà à plus de 700 tir
à tris points tentés hein donc on a une
bonne idée là pour le coup de ce que ça
peut fournir en terme d'adresse c'est
pas des il a TR points tenté ouais donc
c'est assz assez balaise et qu'est-ce
qu' fait du coup parce que là le le tir
c'est ce qu'on achète en premier
qu'est-ce que au niveau du reste est-ce
que c'est anecdotique ou c'est vraiment
une plusvalue je veux dire Manu tu m'as
dit qu'il prenait des harbons vous
m'avez parlé de son jeu de passe aussi
ça me semble des choses intéressantes à
expliquer à ceux qui nous écoutent bah
c'est des qualités qui sont indéiables
et qui en fait ça prennent pas forcément
ouais tu vas pas apprendre à quelqu'un à
aller au rebond à voir la passe et à la
faire c'est quelque chose qui qui est là
c'est c'est en lui donc ces choses là
c'est super intéressant parce que c'est
c'est des choses qui ne s'apprennent pas
donc s'il a déjà faut juste développer
ça et ça peut être que du bonus pour lui
pour pour la suite de sa carrière
Mathias pour toi c'est un vrai plus o on
lui de toute façon j'ai envie de dire on
lui demandera pas ça au niveau au-dessus
s'il y va
non dans un premier temps demandera pas
ça je pense mais c'est toujours un plus
de de savoir faire les passes qu'il faut
surtout avec un bon ratio par rapport
aux pertes de balles perd non plus pas
pas beaucoup de ballon pour pour le taux
de passe qu'il fait et l'utilison qu'
avec le ballon mais c'est sûr que un
premier temps je pense pas qu'on lu
demandera de de de faire le jeu et et
d'être productif à la passe il y a un
autre truc qui est assez intéressant
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui un peu partout
en tout cas cette année sur le terrain
reste à droit peu importe la zone dans
laquelle il est les les stats sous les
yeux tout à l'heure et donc déjà c'est
un énorme footeur de de lancer franc il
est quasiment à 88 % cette année euh il
est à droit aussi bien près du cercle il
est à 65 % ce qui est très honnête mais
aussi loin il est à plus de 50 % pareil
cette differsité là c'est c'est un plus
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on peut lui
demander dans les années futures Manu
non c'est c'est un gros plus et ça
apporté par une belle équipe de Crayton
qui joue très bien au basket en fait
c'est pas une équipe lambda NCA a
beaucoup de mouvements il y a beaucoup
de spacing grâce
à Ashworth et et Alexander qui qui
apporte ça et comme Alexander aussi un
peu ce côté slashheer ben ça ouvre tout
de suite et ça ils en joue énormément
donc c'est c'est un vrai vrai plus pour
lui moi je non c'est un vrai vrai plus
donc c'est ça c'est des trucs pareil qui
qui peuvent l'aider à à connaître déjà
son rôle et avoir un jeu de nos jours
c'est pas un jeu comme un jeu NCA des
années 90 2000 comme on peut toujours le
voir dans certaines équipes comment vous
qualifierez son tir parce que moi je le
trouve quand même un petit peu atypique
dans le style comment on pourrait le
définir pour ceux qui l'ont n'ont jamais
vu jouer Bayer cheerman
ouais ouais bah
c'est c'est pas le enin c'est c'est
casse
quoi j'adore c'est efficace le plus gros
expert des des mécaniques de shoot mais
ouais c'est c'est c'est un shoot qui
part pas forcément très vite moi je
trouve ouais mais qui fait mouche qui
qui demande pas beaucoup de préparation
quoi ouais c'est moi j'ai l'impression
que ça part beaucoup du poignet il est
gaucher si j'ai dis pas de bêtises j'ai
l'impression c'est vraiment un tir du
poignet Manu je sais pas si tu as cette
impression là aussi B c'est vrai que ça
ça part assez bas en fait et comme il
est gaucher bah les gauchés ont toujours
cette forme un peu un peu bizarre et
étonnante de la main de du bras et du
corps et et du coup tu tu sais jamais si
c'est un bon choot ou pas sauf que en
fait comme c'est leur forme à eux bah en
soit c'est un c'est un bon tir mais
c'est vrai que le le ballon est part
d'assez moi ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est que ça part d'assez bas au niveau
du visage et du menton du coup bah faut
qu'il remonte faut qu'il fasse un effort
là-dessus et et bah au niveau supérieur
ça peut être un point faible parce que
du coup les les défenses vont devoir
s'adapter c'est des autres athlètes qui
sont beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup plus
grand beaucoup plus tout et du coup ça
peut peut-être lui demander un temps
d'adaptation pour changer cette cette
forme là cette mécanique mais c'est
c'est du détail moi je le dis toujour
j'ai quasiment peut-être à chaque
podcast c'est que le tir est l'une des
choses les plus simples à travailler h
donc là-dessus s'il a la il pour
l'instant il a les chiffres ça veut dire
qu'il a son tir c'est juste des des mini
choses à évoluer on le voit tous les ans
entre des joueurs draftter et la Summer
League il a il y a quasiment 2 mois et
on voit déjà les les changements che
certains joueurs donc euh comme c'est un
bossurge moi je vois pas trop j'ai pas
trop d'inquiétude là-dessus mais après
faut faut voir si ça peut déranger au
haut niveau en fait c'est c'est juste ça
la forme est est délicate après euh là
on en parle donc qu'on est sur dans une
émission c'est Underdogs donc on on
l'imagine pas forcément être un premier
tour de de draft en fin d'année
prochaine qu'est-ce qui fait
que malgré ses grosses qualités il reste
très perfectible comme comme prospect
hors son âge avancé bah je pense que
c'est c'est la défense he qui va poser
question pour B Sherman on l'a dit tout
à l'heure je crois que c'est Man qui le
disait que c'est pas le le joueur le
plus athlétique h forcément être je
pense ciblé à l'étage supérieur il est
pas ultra mobile maintenant il a quand
même comme il disait Manu plus de ça TR
bon c'est pas pour on a pas comme ça
trop bon faut quand même faut quand même
y aller physiquement il sera pas perdu
parce que c'est quand même un bon bébé
je trouve ouais il a des épaules ouais
ouais il a des belles épaules et puis il
est pas il est pas tout fin quoi et puis
non je pense que ce sera plus niveau de
la mobilité de la lecture défensive qui
qui sera plus ciblé en quoi
ouais Manu on est sur la vitesse de pied
aussi comme défaut principal
ouais après ça je sais pas si c'est très
très très très négatif sachant que c'est
pas un intérieur il joua pas il jera pas
45 donc c vitesse de pied enfin son
footwork ne va pas lui être une une un
outil premier pour son jeu et et gagner
des minutes donc là-dessus je je
comprends ce que tu veux dire mais je
suis pas certain que ce soit un gros
point faible moi c'est plus plus en
terme c'est plus le corps qui me gêne en
fait paril est en il est pas il est B il
est certes large et épais mais il c'est
pas un c'est pas un athlète plus plus il
a encore quelques kilos en trop il peut
encore se former physiquement là-dessus
je pense et c'est il y a un manque de
vitesse il y a un manque sur la défense
en un contre un il est très bon off ball
je trouve mais sur le un contrein il a
beaucoup plus de mal donc c'est c'est
c'est moi c'est un tout notamment
défensif qui me qui me gêne un
peu si on si l'équipe qui le qui le
draftte a un plan pour lui je pense que
ça peut être un un très très une très
très belle
pioche parce que après dans moi dans la
façon don le dont vous me le décrivez
pardon il y a il y a des noms comme ça
qui popent dans mon esprit je pense à
des joing girls des samuser des Duncan
Robinson bien sûr parce que c'est
toujours l'exemple qu'on prend un petit
peu de façon facile est-ce qu'on est un
petit peu dans cette veine là moi j'aime
bien la comparaison joingles gaucher un
peu un peu un peu j'ai perdu le mot
créateur non c'était beaucoup plus
péjoratif que ça un peu Chubby vraiment
le je trouve que les corps se
ressemblentu mais c'est c'est exactement
ça tuas des des Boyan Bogdanovic des
Ingles c'est c'est ce type de joueur là
exactement qui tu tu peux le trans tu
peux le transférer en fait parce que tu
as déjà des des rôles comme ça qui
existent oui voilà en soit moi je en
second tour si une équipe a plusieurs
seconds tours moi je je pense que je
tente le coup après c'est vrai qu'il a
déjà 23 24 ans c'est c'est peut-être ça
le la limite chez lui c'est que à quel
point les équipes vont voir un un
potentiel et une amélioration possible
chez lui c'est plus ça le le truc
justement vu qu'on est sur la projection
euh un second tour on y croit quand même
pour l'année prochaine ou pas Mathias
bah ouais on y croit au moins au moins
un touet mais je pense que euh un second
tour c'est clairement possible surtout
quand on voit les les équipes surtout
les les prétendants au titrre qui qui
font de plus en plus chercher des
joueurs déjà prêts dans un rôle
spécifique je pense que c'est clairement
possible que qu'il se fasse
drafter Manu on est dans la même vibe on
y croit quand même
ouais moi j'y crois parce que les
les chiffres sont trop bons pour le
laisser passer je je je pense qu'une
équipe rien que sur ses pourcentages va
se dire il y a moyen quand même tu vois
il peut rendre service sur sur quelques
bout de match après faut faut le bon
contexte faut la voilà c'est c'est un
tout faut je je sais pas comment on n
pas les Intel devant nous ce qui est
aussi très important dans ces sélections
là faut voir comment il va se se
débrouiller sur les les interviews
puisque ça peut faire monter des des
joueurs en flèche je dirais pas le nom
mais il y en a un cette année qui a qui
a
bondi parce qu'il parle bien devant les
gens donc faut faut voir mais je moi le
le le second tour je tente honnêtement
tranquillement après je je me c'est ce
que je disais à HUG en en off c'est je
je pense que ce garslà il sera d' second
tour et ça va terminer sa carrière
tranquillement en Euroleague ouais c'est
pas impossible c'est pas impossible en
plus il serait il pourra être très très
sympa aussi à voir jouer en Europe pour
complètement être un mec qui met des
points beaucoup de points en eurolleague
on peut le penser en tout cas ouais mais
je franchement je pense qu'il peut avoir
sa chance en NBA enfin sur ce qu'on voit
on n pas tous les éléments parce que
voilà il manque les Intel il manque
plein de choses mais sur ce qu'on peut
voir moi j'ai pas j'ai pas trop de je me
dis qu'une équipe va forcément tenter le
coup surtout dans une draft qui est pas
qui est pas la meilleure du monde donc
est-ce qu'on a encore des choses à dire
sur notre ami Bayer cheerman qui n'est
pas le J non plus le plus esthétique à
voir jouer on va pas se mentir si vous
l'avez jamais vu jouer ne vous attendez
pas un estète du du ballon orange on est
d'accord sur ça ou pas après fil je m'en
fout de ça
dégain Mo qui fait ce qu'on lui demande
de faire il peut avoir des d une
moustache un mulet c'est pas grave
messieurs je vous propose de terminer
avec shman et de passer à l'autre
prospect du jour en la personne de
Matthew Merel donc on va aller direction
all Miss dans le Mississippi qui est pas
vraiment une FA connue pour produire des
basketteurs mais plus du football
américain je crois Mathias
ouais c'est totalement ça mais dans une
dans une grosse conférence quand même ah
oui évidemment ouais bah du coup mat
Morel c'est un un joueur d' 93 pour 91
kil mett TR d'envergure selon le dernier
NBA combine qu'il a fait avant la
dernière draft c'est un senior qui est
en 4e année aujourd'hui et qui va qui
vient d'avoir 22 ans il quelques jours
donc ça va c'est pas un senior trop trop
vieux un 2001 je crois c'est ça un 2001
euh pour faire la ligne statistique là à
l'heure où on parle il a 17 points de
moyenne 41 % à 3 points sur presque 6
tentatives par match 48 % au
global quatre rebonds trois passes et
plus de deux styles par match du coup
matthw Morel c'est un c'est un gars qui
vient de la prestigieuse IMG académie au
lycée ouais cétait une recrue 4 étoiles
Top 40 dans le pays qui a décidé d'aller
au lesis chez les rebels avec une
réputation de gros défenseurs une
première saison freshman ou un peu
poussive avant d'exploser entre
guillemets pour sa saison so fois mort
mais son année junior elle va être très
compliqué à titre personnel mais surtout
titre collectif euh parce que son équipe
elle va finir la saison avec trois
victoires pour 15 défaites en conférence
donc très compliqué et lui bah il va
avoir ses pourcentages complètement
chutés perdre carrément 10 % sur sur le
CH global et sur le ligne à trois points
donc donc forcément les gens n'ont plus
trop parlé de lui mais là cette année
c'est très bien repris sous l'impulsion
de du nouveau coach le fameux Chris bird
qui qui avait été viré de de Texas
exactement euh d'ailleurs qui a un peu
l'équipe surprise de ce début de saison
de SCC parce qu'ils ont plutôt tendance
à comme tu l'as très bien dit être
plutôt dans le fin fond des classements
et là ils sont plutôt au contraire tout
en haut bah là ils sont à à 12-0 c'est
une équip vaincu dans le pays exactement
comment elle est composé cette équipe
d'olmis j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un
gros noyau de joueurs seniors ouais il y
a pas mal de joueurs seniors euh il y a
il y a l'arrivée de Allen flaningan qui
venent de auurn ou lui aussi renait un
peu d'ailleurs et quiip intéressant et
puis forcément Chris bird avait besoin
d'intérieur donc il a il a récupéré des
des gros mastodontes seniors moussassiss
j Shark qui fait plus de 2,2 lui je
crois ouais ça 75 même ouais donc deux
gros intérieurs ouis qui qui colent
parfaitement à son jeu qui qui composait
beaucoup d'écrans beaucoup de screen et
beaucoup beaucoup de mouvement quoi très
bien qu'est-ce qui Pope selon toi quand
on regarde Matthew Mel qui de fait n'est
pas le prospect le plus connu parce que
olimis encore une fois c'est pas c'est
pas connu pour son programme basket
ouais mais en le regardant jouer je
pense qu'on sait vite l'idée du concept
frendy hein évidemment moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est sa défense il a il a un
cororep hyper bien développé il a des
épaules super carrées et il est il est
musclé et puis c'est un très très bel
athlète je trouve que le défenseur est
vraiment très très sous côté il y a
plein de joueurs qui sont mentionnés
mais lui il l'est jamais euh que ce soit
sur l'homme ou loin du ballon moi il
m'impressionne le plus loin du ballon
c'est c'est plus rare en NC souvent les
joueurs ils sont très forts sur l'homme
mais mais moins moins loin du ballon il
excelle il excelle vraiment dans la
lecture des des passes des a et cetera
il est à 2,33 interception par match
c'est quand même assez énorme et puis et
puis ouais il est toujours très
concentré il est souvent placé sur le
meilleur extérieur adverse ouais c'est
c'est un super défenseur Manu même son
chez toi ou tu vois quelque chose
d'autre jaqu totalement moi j'ajouis
vraiment le le tir c'est moi pour
l'avoir vu un peu en enfin découvert en
en High School c'est vraiment moi ce qui
m'avait sauté aux yeux quand quand je
l'avais pour la première fois et on on
voit que ça continue il a il a quasiment
35 % à 3 points sur 4 saisons NC c'est
juste incroyable et comme mathas disait
ça 3e saison il est à 30 % mais
autrement il est à 38 cette année il est
à 40
avec plus de 5 tentatives par match
quasiment 6 donc le l'échantillon est
assez assez impressionnant donc moi
c'est vraiment ça qui qui me saute aux
yeux avec la défense effectivement il a
c'est un c'est un vrai athlète il a un
vrai corps j'étais impressionné aussi
par ça son envergure je la pensais pas
si grande que ça sauf qu'elle est ultra
positive pour lui il a 6 il a il a 62
donc il a
1 quelque chose comme ça donc ouais j'ai
90 63 peut-être j'ai 64 moi avec
chaussur ouais voilà donc 6 3 91 qui il
fait gr modo pour une wi fan à plus de 2
m donc c'est c'est quand même super
impressionnant et je trouve que ça se
voit pas forcément à l'écran en fait ça
ça saute pas forcément aux yeux alors
que finalement il a un corp assez assez
dingue pour pour ce qu'il fait j'aime
beaucoup sa défense également surtout
euh off Ball et enfin même on ball où il
arrive à des fois Remon à prendre le le
le Bandler qui qui remonte la balle il
le prend quasiment tout terrain il le
fait plusieurs fois par match donc c'est
c'est c'est vraiment intéressant après
j'ai plus de questions sur le le niveau
au-dessus savoir s'il sera capable de
faire autant face à d'autres joueurs et
s'il a s'il sera temp polyvalent
également moi je le vois plus défendre
que sur des arrières en NBA s'il y va
ouis alors que en NC il défend sur
vraiment pas mal de monde donc ça peut
être un une petite limite là-dessus mais
il y a sur un sur un petit second tour
il y a beaucoup de choses qui qui
peuvent faire craquer une équipe je
pense donc là on a par vraiment de son
point fort donc sa qualité
défensive comme vous l'avez mentionné en
premier tous les deux ce qui fait que
pourtant les chiffres offensivement sont
bons tu l'as dit notamment avec cette
année un 40 % à 3 points il a 75 %
grosso modo de carrière au lancer France
qui est correct un PRE shour qu'est-ce
qui fait que on a du mal imaginer mieux
à l'heure actuelle qu'un second tour de
draft pour lui c'est pas c'est pas un
porteur de balle déjà en NC je trouve
ouais le sera encore moins NV et donc ça
déjà forcément ça ça casse un peu la
projection le hendle est pas est pas
incroyable
euh donc
déjà il est mieux loin du ballon et puis
en plus je pense que le midrange c'est
un point à travailler pour lui il a le
shoot extérieur derrière la ligne il a
aussi le shoot au Cercle parce qu'il est
athlétique mais le midrange c'est plutôt
plus compliqué plus plus
maladroit mais ouais je pense que c'est
surtout cette qualité de porteur de
balle qui qui freine complètement sa
sa sa projection et puis c'est pas non
plus un un excellent passeur même s'il a
quand même une bonne moyenne de passe
c'est pas le le passeur le plus le plus
fou le plus fou
ouais il a un rapport ass turnover tout
à fait correct je crois il a tris passe
de de balles perdu quelque chose comme
ça donc ça reste honnête est-ce que tu
penses que son handle l'empêche de créer
son tir à mi-istance et que c'est ça qui
l'empêche aussi
de d'être bon dans ce domaine là parce
que apparemment le tir il l'a quand même
bah complètement même à points je le
vois pas je vois très rarement créer son
shoot c'est surtout des shoot en catch
shoot en sortie d'écran beaucoup dans
des systèmes mais assez rarement il cré
son SH il cré son shoot il pas ça
typiquement un peu un joueur de bout de
chaîn donc ouais
exactement Manu ques sont tes réserves
notre
ami la taille la taille oua
malheureusement il peut pas faire
grandchose
euh son son jeu intrinsèque c'estàd que
comme disait Mathias c'est pas un c'est
pas un arrière qui peut porter la balle
et créer pour les autres du coup ça
limite encore plus la chose il peut
jouer que sur un poste de fait sa taille
le premier pas est trop inexistant ou
trop faible selon selon ce qu'on veut
faire et ouais le handle enfin ce coupe
le premier pas handle en fait lui permet
pas de d'attaquer le panier et de créer
les différences sur son vis-à-vis du
coup bah il est limité à la aux trois
points et c'est comme disait mathas
c'est que c'est beaucoup de catch and
shoot il y a un peu de pullup mais c'est
c'est assez rare finalement alors qui
peut le faire c'est du coup oua c'est
c'est vraiment un un tout euh physique
jeu qui qui fait que malheureusement euh
il a un plafond de verre qui va être
très très compliqué à à casser est-ce
que au niveau euh intelligence basket il
peut il pourrait être un espèce de
connecteur al pas forcément porteur de
balle primaire mais être ce gars qui est
capable de faire la bonne passe au bon
moment quand elle se présente en tant
quand le décalage est fait par
exemple moi je pense je pense que oui je
pense que en rôle de connecteur il peut
être intéressant il il a TR il a trois
passes hein c'est pas j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est pas le plus grand passeur
mais il est pas non plus mauvais il
reconnaît quand même très souvent quand
quand son coéquipier est seul son
intérieur et souvent il il est seul à
l'intérieur il arrive à le trouver et
dès demain je pense que ouais en rôle de
de connecteur il peut tout à fait avoir
sa place comment on le projette donc
est-ce qu'on imagine vraiment est-ce que
ce côté justement manque de playmaking
quand même enfin de
création plus large euh c'est pas
vraiment et et combiné à la taille comme
vous l'avez dit par qu'effectivement si
c'est un bon défenseur mais juste sur un
poste c'est ça va devient tout de suite
un prospect moins intéressant est-ce que
vraiment on on l'achète au deè
tour on va sur des profils qui ont
peut-être plus justement le physique
mais pas forcément qui ont pas forcément
prouvé
bah moi perso je l'achète après le
problème c'est que des des profils comme
ça de d'arrière d'arrière scoreur
athlétique il y en existe énormément h
donc c'est compliqué de de tirer son
dans son épingle du jeu et de se faire
drafter au deè tour maintenant euh il y
a pas beaucoup de joueurs dans ce
concept de friendendy euh à de de sa
taille qui sont aussi fort loin du
ballon et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est très très important en NBA
donc c'est pour ça que moi j'y crois
surtout que il a une vraie vraie
diversité au shoot dans des systèmes il
peut clairement faire Filoche derrière
des derrière des bons poseurs d'écran et
cetera il peut avoir un vrai rôle je
pense moi j'hésite grandement parce que
c'est vrai qu'il a des qualités qui sont
qui sont assez assez sympa et qui se
disent ah peut-être que mais son son
manque de taille de et de création bal
en main pas pour les autres mais
vraiment bal en main c'est comme disait
Maas il a sur le how de l'extrap il y en
a beaucoup et très intéressante mais
vraiment balle en main il a c'est comme
il l'a jamais enfin il est vraiment
beaucoup sur le tris points moi ça me
pose souci par rapport bah du coup par
rapport à sa taille et que finalement il
va être très très vite ciblé parce que
bah il peut faire qu'une chose
finalement c'est tirer encore il a pas
ce côté slashheer il a pas ce côté
création même pour lui pour son tir il y
a pas de création d'espace il y a pas ce
ce genre de chos là qui qui fait qui
peut être intéressant au au niveau
supérieur donc moi j'ai j'ai j'hésite
beaucoup j'ai j'ai envie d'y croire
parce que j'aime beaucoup le j'aime
beaucoup le joueurs mais je s'il est
drafté je pense que ce sera fin de
second tour où où il mais moi je le vois
plus undrafty et choper un touet et
faire ses Games ang jellie et
malheureusement pas y rester longtemps
peut-être un truc à à creuser un petit
peu avant de de conclure sur son match
moral comment on explique pour pour les
auditeurs les les moins aguéris la le
fait que quelqu'un peut être athlétique
sans avoir un bon premier pas bah le moi
de ce que j'entends dans athlétique
c'est c'est pas sauter haut athlétique
c'est plusieurs choses c'est déjà un
corps il est il est vraiment bâti c'est
un athlète tu vois mais c'est pas un
athlète dans le sens où bah il peut il
peut pas comment expliquer ça il a pas
cette création pour lui il y a pas ce ce
body contrôle qui fait que il va pouvoir
gagner des duels en l'air ou ou au sol
c'est aathlète c'est pas juste le dunk
en fait et aller haut c'est c'est c'est
plein de choses c'est de la création
quand il y a moi a quelque chose qui qui
avait pop up sur ce sur ce mot là c'est
avec DONIC où tout le monde disait non
non il est pas athlétique il est pas
athlétique sauf qu'en fait il l' mais à
sa façon c'est un mec qui crée des
espaces dingues avec ses
jambes c'est juste fou il y avait des
photos comme ça qui qui faisaient que il
faisit quasiment des grands écart en
fait quand quand il prenait l'espace et
ça ça c'est être athlète en soi tu vois
mais et ça mat Merel ne l'a pas et il a
outre le corps où il est un athlète il a
pas ce qui ce qui coche toutes les cases
après d'être un athlète plus plus un un
fric comme on peut on peut dire je sais
pas si d'accord avec ça mais si si je
suis d'accord c'est qualité athlétique
c'est pas forcément enfin ça ça englobe
beaucoup de choses c'est qualité de
détente de de rapidité de comme tu dis
de création d'espace lui il a pas la
création d'espace mais il a la rapidité
il a la la mobilité latérale il a la
détente mais c'est vrai que son manque
de de premier pas de coup dein et de
création d'espace ça sera un problème et
et du coup question subsidiaire est-ce
que ça se travaille vraiment ça c'est
pas oui ça se travaille
mais c'est pas le le plus facile à
travailler on va dire on est d'accord
surtout surtout la création d'espace ou
on est d'accord Mathias vu que c'est toi
qui l'a le plus vu donne-nous des bonnes
raisons de regarder all Miss quand
même
parce qu'ils sont invaincus déjà ils
sont invaincus je pense que en plus
s'ils ont une s'il continue leur bonne
lancée et qui font une bonne marche ça
peut mettre de la lumière sur Merel et
puis honnêtement si vous aimez bien les
alè les athlètes il y en a pas mal à
olis traditionnellement toutes les
toutes les facs où il y a beaucoup de
football américains il y a souvent des
athlètes quand même et pas forcément des
des basketteurs ça c'est vrai aussi
cette année ça joue bien au basket àm
donc il faut les regarder ainsi va se
terminer notre
Underdogs 3e épisode on va avoir aussi
une pensée pour le basket français pour
le BCM gravelin parce qu' leur sale est
parti en fumé c'est un petit peu triste
donc on les mentionne et puis on pense
quand même à eux on pense aussi à vous
on vous souhaite de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année un bon Nouvel An revenez en
pleine forme nous on sera là toujours à
bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]
ciao